je m'appelle j'irai me belleau je suis
architecte et artiste plasticien et du
coup j'ai
créé une exposition dans le château de
joncy
ici s'entremêlent son géométrie et
lumière le château du 11e siècle abrite
un art contemporain numérique qui se
marie avec les vieilles pierres
évidemment le lieu est une composante
essentielle et d'ailleurs on a notre
choix dans le projet du château ces deux
de se composer avec l'existant et de ne
pas re composé des espaces à l'intérieur
de l'espace donc on découvre les volumes
dans leur entièreté et la déambulation
se fait de salles en salles à travers
ses oeuvres ils cherchent à mettre en
valeur le patrimoine dans sa boîte à
outils des projecteurs de la musique
mais aussi des modélisations numériques
une oeuvre comme celle ci nécessite plus
de six mois de travail
ici on peut traverser touches et avoir
une approche plus ludique dollars des
créations accessibles il en réalise
depuis 2012 à l'aide de ces ordinateurs
et de ses logiciels jérémy bello
modélise des images sur des monuments
historiques ici ils cherchent à
illuminer le mouv saint michel comment
on vient éclairer l'architecturé quels
sont les effets les ombres qui vont
résulter de la pop de la position d'un
projecteur moi j'ai la chance d'avoir de
faire un travail qui mêle ma passion
pour d'un côté l'architecturé la
géométrie l'image le cinéma et puis la
musique électronique de manière générale
donc on peut pas compter ses heures
aujourd'hui les projets de l'artiste
s'enchaînent ils se préparent pour la
fête des lumières à lyon fin octobre
mais travaille aussi sur un hébergement
au sein de son château on a décidé
d'accueillir des gens dans une forme
d'expérience celle de dormir dans une
oeuvre d'art et pour pouvoir dormir dans
une oeuvre d'art il faut un lit et du
coup on va passer par le système de
d'accueil dans notre château depuis
l'ouverture du château le 13 juillet le
musée a déjà accueilli sept mille
visiteurs mais le couple ne compte pas
s'arrêter là il envisage d'en recevoir
vingt mille dès la première saison